una respuesta a una pregunta no hecha no
es respuesta
repito una respuesta a una pregunta
hecha no es respuesta esa frase le
escuché la ley hace mucho no sé dónde no
recuerdo
hemos sacado conmigo mucho tiempo y se
lo hice empezó y el evento pues
planteando no sé haciendo alusión a que
a veces más importante las preguntas que
nos hacemos en las respuestas que
encontramos no estoy totalmente acuerdo
con él quisiera empezar mi tradición con
esta pregunta
iremos todos en la misma reacción
hace unos años conocí a un vasco en
español que dirige una empresa autobuses
en españa y este señor manejaba fábricas
en españa en chila y tiene una fábrica
en querétaro en méxico y me contó una
historia que se me quedó muy muy muy
grabada y la quiero compartir con
ustedes me dijo que elevaba la atención
como llegaba el trabajador el obrero
mexicano a la peral fábrica en querétaro
los invito a ponerse los zapatos de un
obrero que va llegando en la mañana
laso lugar de trabajo primero conocer
qué sucede cuando llega
pasa fueron de índole mentales
qué es algo muy común en nuestro país
digamos detector de metales para el tren
a la fábrica de empleo no
cuál es el mensaje
no va a robar algo
hay desconfianza completa no sentimos y
estamos el trabajador cuál es la
emocionalidad que nos da el llegar y el
primer mensaje que nos da la empresa
nosotros es no confío en ti porque me
puedes robar
un minuto después de pasar por ahí
es lo que sucede hay un reloj checador
antes usaban tarjetitas y el checaban
ahora ya llegan con la mano de
identificación
cuál es el mensaje
el flojo o o no eres puntual
queremos checar que ese tiempo
no se puede imaginar guitarreros
checador y confiar en que la persona va
a llegar a tiempo y va a ser responsable
muy puntual dos minutos todos nos
pasaron dos minutos y ya nos dijeron a
nosotros trabajadores que vamos a robar
y que somos flojos y poco puntuales no
un minuto después llegas a tu lugar de
trabajo tu máquina y la instrucciones y
que el botón no lo pierdes hay
ingeniería allí en la oficina los
ingenieros son los que saben no tienes
muchas competencias para pensar sólo
pica el nopal
tercer mensaje que no están diciendo
eres incompetente y resulta que los
cinco minutos de que llegamos nosotros
trabajadores a la fábrica nos dijeron me
vas a robar eres un poco flojo y poco
puntual y como no es muy competente no
lo pienses alguien más piensa por ti
qué tanto qué tanta energía que tanto
nos va a dar ese trabajador a la
organización como nos haría sentir eso
cuáles son los mensajes
y lo que quiero plantear y va aquí es lo
siguiente me gusta mucho esta imagen que
también una vez me tope
obviamente con esos mensajes qué
reacción le da el trabajador lo que
sucede es esto si la recepción es un
barco pues habrá algunos que están
remando en la dirección en la
declaración quiere ir va a ver otros que
van a estar a dicha coleando no
haciéndose weyes cubríamos aquí en el
norte y abrieron otros que van a estar
remando en contra
que tanto avanzar esa organización
sum en el entorno hay tormenta alguien
te encontrás olvídense no obviamente no
avanza
y eso vamos a pasarlo al gobierno
o la sanación de la sociedad civil que
se presentó más temprano a la familia
inclusive no lo confío no eres puntual
no sabes
obviamente no avanzamos
y la pregunta es
y tenemos que hacer para que suceda esto
imagínense ese barco si así como quiero
avanzamos un poco imagínense si logramos
esto y esa es la pregunta
yo quiero proponer tres cosas que creo
yo en lo personal podrán ayudar a
cambiar este barco con los que están
haciéndose bueyes los que van para atrás
que todos tenemos remando en una
dirección después de otras ideas
obviamente no sólo dice exhaustiva son
tres cosas que he vivido en las que yo
creo que les quiero compartir
la primera confianza
el justo paga por el pecador
es lo que sucede en las empresas
organizaciones no imagínense los 100
personas un robo una persona que no es
tiene confianza pongan los detectores
metales pongan los policías pongan las
cámaras por esa persona te robo lo que
yo creo es que el costo de desconfiar en
los otros 99 es muchísimo mayor que el
coste de esa persona que no es digna de
confianza
aunque yéndose en 13
y yo sinceramente creo que si hiciéramos
un cambio de mentalidad y confiamos
demás
tendremos a 98 personas o 99 97 remando
en la misma dirección y quizás esas 90 y
100 se harán cargo de que ese 12 no esté
rearmando en contra
fuera detector de metales confianza
además
primer propuesta que yo quiero hacer
será que nos ayuda yo creo que sí
segunda idea
transparencia teniendo la luz les quiero
compartir algo que me gusta mucho la
empresa que me toca dirigir desde hace
más de 20 años nuestro fundador decidió
abrir los libros como dicen en eeuu el
100% el personal más de 2.000 personas
tiene acceso a los resultados del
negocio las utilidades cuánto se gana
inclusive tienen un pedazo de esas
utilidades
y hace como unos 12 o 15 años cuando
estaba muy fuerte el tema de inseguridad
del monterrey viene una consultora de
seguridad
y sorpresa lo primero que dijo fue ese
tema de que sea transparente hay que
quitarlo
muy peligroso
y la nación dijo así propone lo que
quieras menos quita esa transparencia
les digo con mucho orgullo que nuestra
empresa cuando viene hacen climas
organizacionales y nos revisan se
sorprenden mucho los externos porque
tenemos un compromiso tan alto de
nuestra gente yo atribuyo mucho esto
transparencia
la cual falta muchísimo lo ofrece el
gobierno transparente en la casa
transparencia organización
yo creo que sirva los más transparentes
además que entre el mando a la derecha
si confiáramos demás
y fuimos transparentes demás
segunda idea
tercera participación
valorar las diferencias vamos otra vez
el historial trabajador
y es algo muy sencillo pero muy poderoso
si ese trabajador en lugar de decirle
que el botón no piensa decimos qué
opinas qué has aprendido que se ve desde
tu perspectiva juntos vamos a solucionar
este problema obviamente
y hacer esto o hacer esto tiene mucho
más probabilidades de que quieran amar
en conjunto con los demás si hay un tema
más profundo eso realmente creer el
valor de diferencias no importa de dónde
vienen la persona
para mí eso es poderosísimo y también
lo que yo les planteo así de simple
es que si de veras viviéramos en un
mundo de más confianza
el mundo más transparente
el mundo más participativo
definitivamente va a ser mucho más
rápido definitivamente cambiaremos la
imagen primera del barco a la segunda
y me despido preguntándoles ustedes qué
idea se siente ocurre a ti
muchas
[Aplausos]